THE HIT.
LANDESKOG THROWING HIS BODY
THAT FROM THE TIME
HE DEBATE HERE. A REVERSE HIT.
HEARINGS MAKAR.
HEHE
HEAVY LINE INSIDE  SETTLE THING.
TURNS, FIRES.
SAVED BY INGRAM, OFF AND BURAKO
WITH THE W
TOEWS.
MAKAR.
TO THEY IT BACK OFF.
TO
RATTANEN.
MAKAR AGAIN.
RANTANEN HOLDING AND Shane: COS.
CARRIER TRYING TO O T
THERE AHEAD OF MNOT ONLY IN THE
NEUTRAL ZONE.
>> Dave: PUCK LOOSE OFF THE
SNAPSHOT.
>> Chris: A COUPLE OF GR INGRA
NASHVILLE TRY TO O O  TRYING TO
HOIST IT, AND BINNINGTON T
REBOUND AND HE GOT THAT ONE,
TOO!
SNAPS IT.
NEVER GOT IT THROUGH.
BINNINGTO
TH QUICKER.
>> Brendan: SHOTS ON GOAL IN AN.
CO WITH THE
PUCK.
>> Brendan: 25 WINFENDAMENTIALS
BACK INTO THE PLACE. WAY OUT.
WORKING AROUND
THERE IS A PASS, WE ARE INTO TH.
GLOVED DOWN BY BYRUM
KADRU THE 9 OFcKINNON.
HAS TWO IN THE IN A HURRY.
LEDDY THOUGHT ABOUT GOING TO THE
BENCH.
AT LEAST ON THE GAME 5, OVERTIME
MAKES
MANSON.
>> Eddie: FI
AND NOW, PUCK KNOCKED DOWN B: C.
TOGETHER THAT.
>> Eddie: GREAT PLAY FOR
ONE BAD PASS, OKAY.
TWO?
G IT FOR
PUCK LOOSE.
MacKINNON TOOK A WHACK AT IT AND
12.
TAKEN AWAY BY NICHCH CBC
GEM.
>> Craig: JARED BEDNAR GOES
RIGHT WITH THE TOP LINE.
THEY JUST GOT T AT TAKES A STICT
OF THE HANDS OF FRANCOUZ.
OILERS WIN IT.
NUGENT-HOPKINS AND THAT
PASS AND GET A CHANGE FOR THE
PENALTY KILLERS.
LANDESKOG COMES IN.OME TO LANDE.
DOWN. STICK OF DRAISAITL.
AND HERE'S MacKINNON. WLLINE WIE
SENT HIS TEAM IN OVERTIME TO TH.
TURNED 21 ON MONDAY.
SHOT ON -- GOAL! CHANCE FOR
NICHUSHKIN, HE SCORES! CUPS.
THEY CONTINUE TO DO IT.WHOOK BE.
TAMPA BAY NOW WITH A SERIES
AGAINST COLORADO WILL HAVE
PLAYED THE THREE HIGHESTMANSON.
HELM HAS SOME OPEN ICE.
HELM TAKES A SHOT AND SCORES! T.
MAKAR W
NOW LEAVES IT FOR BY.
GABRIEL LANDESKOG DUMPED IT BAC
EIGHT ROADCROSS-ICE PASS.
RANTANEN PUT IT ON AND A REBOUND
HELM THROUGH IT ON N N COUNTER ,
IT'S KADRI BACK PAYOFF FOR
COLORADO.
MAKAR.
VASILEVSKIY.
CUP IF THEY WIN IT.
THE POINT, AND HE DOES.
A S